now when you can go off and do stuff
like this in between i'm sure you did
this between seasons of riverdale um
what is that like for you when you get
to go back to riverdale i mean it feels
like i was able to accomplish i feel
accomplished you know i don't like to
sit around during my hiatuses although
that's what i'm doing this summer but
i'm enjoying that but it makes me feel
like okay we're keeping the train moving
because as much as i love riverdale i
obviously want to do other things
outside of it so i feel i feel good and
always like okay
we did it yeah checks check something
off the list i like that though because
i feel like well this is going to be the
last hiatus potentially for a while
right
so you got to relax a little bit i am
rela yeah i'm enjoying i'm going to
travel next month and see my family and
because i think it's going to be quite
crazy when riverdale ends in the best
way for me because i like to keep
working have you started to process what
it will mean for that show to come to an
end yeah and it's sad it makes me it
makes me sad i it's truly the end of an
era of my life a big chapter of my life
and i'll miss my cast so much and
you know it's the last time that we all
will be collectively filming something
together so i think we're just going
into this season knowing that we're
really going to try to cherish it this
season finale kind of threw everyone for
a loop
heading back to the 1950s how do you
want to see bay's journey wrap up i
think we'll eventually come out of the
1950s i would assume but i i would
obviously like to see um
a happy ending for betty knowing that
she will be
she will be okay an optimistic
lighthearted note i don't know who she's
gonna end up with or
where how why when i know nothing about
the final season but
um
but i just hope that she's that she's
happy and you have an idea that things
are going to settle down for her in the
best way i'm sure there's a text chain
with you guys has it gotten a little
weepy yet oh definitely not we all kind
of know i mean we spend so much time
together during our filming season that
when it is our hiatus we're all like bye
and and we do keep in contact with each
other for sure like i talked to cammy
and mads and vanessa all the time in
machin but
but everyone's busy everyone's doing
their things and we know that we're
coming back to each other so it's not
it's not weepy yet
[Music]
it's not just one moment that defines
your life
it's all the moments
i mean what was it like for you to be
able to stretch your creative muscles as
not only a performer but as an executive
producer on this as well it's very
satisfying i feel i feel very lucky it's
it's kind of it's surreal it's it's you
know
yeah i'm at a loss for words a little
bit it's it's wonderful it's the first
time i've had a premiere where a lot of
my family and friends are here so it
feels really special yeah you're in good
hands tonight right i am in good hands
and i love my
my people yeah yeah so what would your
life look like if you hadn't pursued
performing and
acting
depressing i guess i
i mean acting is the only thing that i
truly ever really knew that i wanted to
do
so that's why i didn't have a backup
plan
i mean i had considered being a
paramedic at one point possibly a makeup
artist very different things
but i'm glad that this worked out
because i think this is what was
supposed to happen so yeah at the end of
the film that both versions of your
character kind of come to the same
conclusion what do you want the audience
to take away from this if it has an
underlying message well when i read the
script i really resonate i mean i just
thought it was so heartwarming and i
usually don't like
heartwarming movies to be honest i'm
more drawn to the darker stuff but this
one felt just so sweet and comforting
knowing that there's a million different
ways that your life can look and there
is no right or wrong path and that just
felt really beautiful to me and i hope
that people who are watching it however
old they are on their teens in their 20s
30s whatever and you know who has that
question of what if what if i did this i
think the grass is always greener and
you can see that in this movie that both
paths are equally
beautiful yeah it was like spending time
with that baby on set there were
multiple babies
yeah we had a couple babies and our
twins um it was yeah they cried for sure
those babies really did they were crying
but and we felt i felt so bad i was like
i know i can't comfort you i'm not your
actual mother but please pretend like
you love me yeah yeah it's intense i
have two kids in the crying it doesn't
it never gets easier oh okay yeah yeah
well
that's everyone the cards for you it's
still going to be equally as difficult i
can't wait i'm excited
you